no man's sky is already an ambitious
game but what if it ran on more powerful
hardware like the upcoming playstation
borneo console well hello games director
Sean Murray has some ideas I'm Lucy and
welcome to your reach for the sky
gamespot news update Sean Murray told
the Daily Star that putting no man's sky
on better hardware could fundamentally
change the experience in the interview
Murray explain why no man's sky is
uniquely positioned to benefit from a
release on such a control he said if you
play another game and if they do a
remaster of that game what they will do
is uh press the textures and things like
that that's because the base geometry
the base shape of the world the way of
playing is totally like lost basically
hundreds of people have worked on it
thousands of hours to create what you
see for our game it's procedurally
generated so more powerful hardware
doesn't just mean upgraded textures or
higher framerate it means we can
fundamentally change the experience
Larry went on to say that hello games is
able to change huge things through
patches to no man's sky with more
powerful hardware we can have more trees
more leaves on those trees the density
or immersion of worlds or new types of
worlds could exist but before you get
excited bear in mind that Murray is
speaking hypothetically as no plans have
been announced yet for a beefier version
of no man's sky for neo Murray has
already talked about growing and
expanding no man's sky through future
updates in a blog post on Monday who
said 50 hope for things like pvp
multiplayer or city building piloting
freighters or building civilizations
that isn't what no man's sky is over
time it might become some of those
things through updates two of those
things freights and base building are on
the way the recent reveal of the game's
big launch update revealed those
features and some visual enhancements
are next up so are you playing no man's
sky is it everything you dreamed of and
more let me know in the comments I'll
come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games for all the latest make sure
you keep it gamespot
you
you